Trump won and I and I like to say that I
hope that I helped him win the
presidency because I would get up in
front of 25 000 people at rallies going
leading into the 2016 and I would
introduce him as the most imperfect guy
you're ever going to vote for president
and people would go nuts American people
don't want Perfection American people
want somebody who loves this country
somebody who loves this country and
somebody who actually
sounds like they know what they're doing
and then when they get in and and again
he was a he proved himself in his own
track record as a businessman in the
media and all this so he had a bit of a
proven track record now he's been in the
now he's been a president
and he's got a great proven track record
with all of the craziness that he's had
to deal with to include guys like me
being cut out from underneath his knees
right
and and there was some and this this is
not just on the Democrats or on Obama
okay there are some and we call it the
unit party you know the we we Define the
unit party in this book so there are
some in the uniparty in the
establishment of Washington D.C that
likes the way things are operating and
some of those were right inside the
White House okay and and uh so they were
they were already surrounding him
and they definitely did this to a degree
in the campaign but I don't think we
realized it to the degree that we
realized that I realized it later he
definitely has realized that
um now as many people and as great of an
Enterprise as he has in this in the
whole Trump orbit you know you you still
when you get into politics when they say
it's a blood sport it's a death cult
okay it's not a blood sport it's a death
cult and they will kill you now these
days like I said this and they kill you
by narrative now so so there are people
in and around the Inner Circle that also
were part of this I mean he had the two
houses right the tri-cameral system we
got Judiciary legislative and executive
he had the the uh the legislative on his
team for the first two years build the
wall right
pass all kinds man did he have a tough
time why because the people that were
there hated him they hated him more than
they loved this country and you know so
I mean you got me another one of these
soap boxes are those people that he had
some of them are still there some of
them are still there some of them are
running for president some of them are
are external to the um the uh the
Washington DC Circle but they're now in
places in the media and they're you know
they're doing other little they're
they're they're out there still and
they're still uh wanting to get actually
they're still on somebody's payroll in
some cases well this goes back to my
initial question so these are things of
so I'm sorry sir so these are things
that get back to your your uh your great
question Pat these are things that I
know okay no going in so these aren't
things that I'm just now imagining
okay or these aren't conspiracies right
these are things or conspiracy theories
these are things that I knew going in
and and I'm trying to also take a take a
national security apparatus
case you can look at all the agencies
and activities but also the the
structure of people inside the White
House I walk into the White House so
under under the cold during the Cold War
at the height of the Cold War where we
had nuclear against nuclear uh we had
National Security advisors that had like
25 to to 40 people inside the White
House work you know and when in the
white house there's a there's a couple
little buildings around it but like less
than 50 people at the height of the Cold
War where we had a half a million troops
stationed over in Germany or over in
Europe half a million today we barely
and we today we might have you know 60
60 70 000 half a million with all kinds
of capabilities to go to war right we
had maybe 25 to 50 people in the
National Security team of the White
House when I walk in the door there's
500 people 500 people you know again you
know you you swing a cat you're gonna
hit somebody that's on the national
security staff you see all these people
in the media that sit on places like
this and you know National National
Security something right I mean so many
people if you you need an expert if you
need an expert in the White House you go
ask for one I want an expert on on
business or entrepreneurship or gold or
I'll get somebody I'll reach out to the
best in the world certainly the best in
this country I don't need to have 500
people wandering around the halls
wondering what the hell they're going to
do I I used to call them when I did go
to the finally go to the Pentagon used
to call them wall Walkers wall Walkers
because you would go down the hallways
of the Pentagon you ever been in the
Pentagon so you get down the hallways of
the of the Pentagon and you see people
coming I'm one of these I like to engage
right I like to say hey how you doing
today right that's the way I am so you
see these people and they'd walk along
the wall and they'd just be kind of
looking at the wall like looking at the
pictures because they didn't want
anybody to grab them they didn't want
anybody to say hey because if they were
afraid if somebody grabbed them these
are wall Walkers now in the Pentagon if
somebody grabbed them they were afraid
that they were going to have to go do
some work
okay and I use that metaphorically
because we got a lot of people wander
around in our government right now
so that's that's the other part about
this it's to say look
what are we doing are we going to have a
federal a federalism where are we going
to have a a bloated government and
everything is controlled by Washington
DC and you know and we're we're we have
well I'll use I'll use my buddy Klaus
and your buddy Klaus right we own
nothing and we're happy right we know
nothing and we're happy so when you have
that
I know all that I knew all that going in
and they had to really
they took on that fifth of January day
and I keep going back to that because
this is public information now
they use the full weight of the
resources of the United States
government to get the sitting National
Security advisor
who was already chosen by a duly elected
president of the United States out of
office as fast as they can as fast as
they could the full weight of all
resources in the United States
government that they could bring to bear
okay and It ultimately is wasn't that on
Trump though you were forced to resign
because Trump he publicly made that
speech he's good guys I know Trump said
he lied to me but
yeah I said well he lied he lied right
right so but you still have his bag I do
how do you grapple with that yeah it's a
big thing I mean yeah because you could
you could say and I've been you know
public about that could be his worst
enemy right right I sat through I sat
through as a cooperating Witness
with the Mueller invest the fake Mueller
investigation because I knew that there
was nothing there okay and they asked
you so yeah so why do I why do I stand
with this guy
and it's not so much that I stand with
with Trump as a as a as an entity like a
lot of people you know people are
enamored they want to get photos they
want to you know want to get a signed
hat I stand with Trump because right now
unless it's a guy like
you or somebody else out there right now
he's the warrior that has put himself
and his entire family his entire
Enterprise
you know on the docket to to help this
country I know one thing about Trump
trump loves America he absolutely he
dearly dearly loves America and when you
see somebody in their sort of worst
moments and there was times and
particularly during the 2016 campaign
that I saw him like that uh you know or
that I had conversations you know
intimate conversations with him about
this country because we you know we met
2015 right I'm not like some you know
long-lost buddy from New York that
played baseball with him right I mean
and um and and he loves his family so I
so when I and I saw him do things to
four people for just the regular guy or
regular guy I saw him do things when
nobody else was looking in the military
you know you're judged you're judged by
what you do when nobody else is looking
okay your standard is your standard when
nobody else is looking you know you're
you know you're a lieutenant you're a
private you're told pick up the
cigarette butts right and maybe you're
walking down the street and nobody's
telling you to do it but you do it
because you just know it's the right
thing on a you know on a military base
or on your yard right somebody throws
trash in your yard nobody's you know
whatever
this is a guy that loves this country he
loves the direction of this country he
wants to be just like it is just like
the Constitution allows
where we have another element
we have a very dangerous element in this
country very dangerous and when they say
me to me the point at me and they go is
a threat to democracy
this isn't a democracy this is a
constitutional republic but they never
say he's a threat to the constitutional
republic you don't hear the parrots out
there going what do you fear the most
right now what are you most concerned
about right now with America I mean I
know you we talk yes globalism versus
nationalism you got to stop not
nationalism not nationalism americanism
americanism okay so what what is your
biggest concern what's the biggest
threat we have in America right now yeah
I I uh I think the speed
uh I I pray that that the speed in which
we are moving toward
uh sort of the end the end of times the
end times here
um is moving faster than most people
uh can can sense you know so that's my
my anxiety I guess if I if I wake up at
times and I think man
you know can we do this can we you know
so the speed in which things are
happening uh and I think it's purposeful
now I don't think it's no there's no
more hiding of what it is that they're
they're trying to do and when I say they
to the audience you know to you guys
here I mean it's a it's a it's a it's a
globalist crowd you know world if you
had a headquarters uh like you got the
Commanding General 101st Airborne or
82nd you know or whatever
um you know you got the world economic
forum and Klaus Schwab is kind of the
face and then you have like he said a
couple of weeks ago we have 600 of the
smartest people in the world right I
mean so then you have uh World bodies
World Health World Bank World Trade uh
international monetary fund uh Europe
you control the European Union as sort
of an unelected subset uh United Nations
uh and there's other Global globalist
alliances and bodies and we'll and maybe
I'll talk about global alliances but I
think the speed that we're moving so how
do you how do you overcome that
you know how do you overcome that and uh
and actually I only because I I think
you've you've actually I I use the
phrase local action has a national
impact but you uh you gave six or seven
uh things in the end of your uh your
pitch there the other day which I
thought were good in terms of what can
people do so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you